Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to One Shot
now, I meant to get to this sooner, but we were busy with the live stream and various other things
but I will do more regular episodes of this
Maybe even daily  because I'm really intrigued by this
I just loaded up the game and then Niko started talking to me
he was like calling out my name and he says...
He's like kinda panicked that I'm not responding
So I'm gonna find out what Niko wants...to say to me-here "Mark can you hear me?"
Yeah, yeah I can "Oh phew, what happened? Everything went pitch black for a second."
Oh
Ooooohhhhhhhhh
Because I closed the game
oH nO
ok... alright then
oh that's super weird-Ok we last left off is-uh-we just got the iron bar
Which I should be able to use to uh... fold in the machine or something with that effect
er-like be able to pry something out of something else
oh yeah
"Something in the area, It hurts to breath"
I need a gas mask to be able to go any farther north, but
as far as I know, I've reached the ends of the maps, besides-woah hello...
Hi ...who are you?
"Hello?"...uh "Markiplier, are you there?"
YES I AM
what would happen if I say no?...
NO?
I'm assuming this is a sarcastic response
"Aw bummer...wait. You just answered me!"
"You sure have a sense of humor Markiplier"
yeah...that's me
"There's a robot here, attached to a boat"
"It doesn't seem to have power and its joints are rusted over as well"
"But I think we should be able to fix it"
"After all, we'll need to cross this ocean to get to the Tower"
ooooookaaaaaay
So we need to find a way to fix that and I shouldn't be so sarcastic to Niko that seems mean
I'm gonna try to be a bit more serious about my responses here
BUT THEN AGAIN... I've been given a modicum of power and I have no idea how to handle that
So I'm gunna take this iron bar that I got and I should be able to use it on something here
to give that robot power...
Because if that's my logic here then that's an acceptable way to go...
Maybe this guy's got advice here...Hello again!
noooo...no more questions...alright
aw thanks for the safe travels
OH Wait wasn't it in here, there was something over, wait
can I...can I use this or something? "It's a power cell I think-OH the word prophetbot is written on the side"
"Didn't notice that earlier"
OHHHHHH, so the this is the power source for that prophet bot outside
and then the other character, the red-haired robot over in the eastern area (Silver), that was their power cell...
So they're both robots, which is really weird because the other one is "tamed" and I don't know what that means...
weird.......
Something used to fit in there so I could either put something in there or I could put something in the robot
or maybe do a transitional thing here and there
"This box looks interesting, I wish I had something to pry it open with"
Maybe I DO!
"The screwdriver's not nearly big enough to pry it open" Ok, how 'bout the metal rod?
"The pipe won't fit in the cracks...we need to fi-"OHHH Ok I know what I need to do!
Ok, I'm smart  and I have and idea of how to flatten
things with machinery, I'm not able to flatten the light bulb...
Guess I can flatten someone else....
Something else, not someone else, I don't have any intention to flatten anybody, especially Niko
alright, flatten this
"Ah, do you want me to crush the pipe in here Markiplier? ooo but I don't want to get too close..."
BE BRAVE!
"That was scary..." oh you did it, oh good job Niko! You were so brave!
ok so now we got it-well I guess technically we got a crowbar now
So what do I do with this screw driver... "Hope we don't have to use this again Markiplier..."
Well I don't know if we will...you might have to be brave a few more times before we get to the end of this adventure
Okay, so if I have the screwdriver...what could that be used for?
Because if I need something big to pry the Power Cell out of this one, I don't know...
Yeah, I don't know what we need in the long run...
This bar should open it...okay "There's a little metal cube and some broken glass in here"
"looks like what used to be a machine part"
"it says Solar battery on the side" okay...well I got a solar battery and maybe I'll be able to charge it in the light of this thing...
So if I take...not that, but the broken battery..."a lot of small glowing shrimp"
huh...
Maybe if I put it in here "the battery fits into the slot perfectly! Looks like we're on the right track, but nothing happened..."
huh...so there's got to be a way to- maybe if I combine this with the light bulb...
agh "Feels like we're on the right track for this, I don't think we can do anything else"
But maybe I can combine the screwdriver and that, no, maybe that and that? no
Maybe I can fill the empty bottle with some shrimp from one of the pools
and then combine that uh ok
a little bit of loading lag there
and then combine that with what I need
because there's got to be a reason I have the screwdriver
I've been walking around pretty much everywhere here
And the only things that I don't have are means to power this Power Cell
It fits in that slot perfectly but what does that mean?
because I can't interact with these pools at all
huh, but there was something  about the notification saying if you see a particularly bubbling pool
you were supposed to contact authorities eh-immediately because that could be a source of power
because I'm assuming that those jars that are filled with the phosphorescent like uh shrimp
in there that they're some sort of light which is the only power source in this entire place
so there's gotta be in one of these pools here a particularly glowing, or bubbling
Piece of water and that would mean that I'll be able to get some shrimp from it
unless I need a fishing rod or something like that or-wait
"I can see a green glow in the distance"
wait where did the row- where the row boat go?
ok so he says "I don't think this battery is supposed to be for the robot"
which means this battery is for that other thing down below
and if I were to combine...*sigh* if I were to combine this with a Power Cell of some sort
then I would be able to power it
at least that's what I thought
"The Sun will not return and the abyss is calling my name, I'm sorry everyone..."
"for choosing to leave before the darkness suffocates us all"...
well that's sad
I mean what would you do if you were faced with like just knowing that the world was gonna end
if nothing was gonna save it, I guess it would be pretty depressing
in the long run but....yeesh
But maybe- maybe the person who was over here knows something about what's going on
do we need further assistance? I think we do!
I think we might need it, can you help me with this?
Oh ok, I guess we're so strong that we know what we're gonna do...
"The top is covered with the wire mesh..." Can I take one of these jars of glowing shrimp?
or...you need them, real badly?
can you live without them?
alright...alright
so there must be some place that I use
so I've got this screwdriver, so the only place I haven't gone is further to the east
so I'm gunna go over there and see if there's something that I can use there
"WAIT" okay, alright then
"I saw you heading towards this direction, the mines have been abandoned for a long time"
"I cannot guarantee that it's safe"
"If you must enter it, it is my duty to accompany you at least once"
"Oh thanks!" Oh, cool!
let's go in the mines I guess, together, alone- what is that?
"There's a little gadget on the ground, kinda looks like a camera"
"What's left of a camera anyway"
"Probably even a part of a robot at one point"
"oh..." "Or not, I do not know"
Alright I'll take it then, your lack of knowledge doesn't disturb me
alright, "another one of those shrimp jars"
but they're just laying around, if those can be used for power I wonder why they're just used for light
"I can see a faint yellow glow in the distance"
"Don't stand so close to the edge" "Oh, sorry!"
"Looks like even the entrance tunnel collapsed off"
"Without a vehicle, we can't proceed"
"Can't we walk?"
"I can, But for you, it's a safety violation, I won't allow it"
"What's ahead, anyway?
"It's a huge network of underground mines, the source of this world's metal and non-phosphor fuel"
"This is what propelled the world into the industrial age"
"So now it's lost forever?"
"It's been for a while now"
"When the sun went out, the mines were the first to be abandoned amidst the initial panic"
"Even the robots have been all cleared out and repurposed"
"That makes sense"
"Though there was one that always insisted on going back"
"Oh?" "I hope he's ok"
So who went back down in the mines?
Why would they go back down in the mines?
"The yellow light is gone now, must've imagined it"
So that might have been the robot that's still down there
"Do be careful in here"
Alright, I will try but there's nothing else to be careful for
I don't have a vehicle and the tracks still meet up with the cart
"Ready to leave?"  I guess, there's nothing here besides that robot that's still working
down in the mines
I mean I think, if that's even what it actually is
So is there nothing else here? No,
that was literally it, that was just one more step over to the right, and then we got this camera,
so there's got to be something to do with this camera that we have here
What is that for, can't combine those
AHH use the screwdriver to pull the lens out, ok, alrighty then
DONE
YAY we got a lens, I don't know what-"a large glass lens"
Can I combine that? "the lens pops right in" Holy Crap
Alrighty then, so maybe that was all we needed or maybe this; "We're using the sun directly on the battery?"
"I would have never thought of that"
Well I mean, I think we thought of that, we were kind of on the right track before
but I don't know why that's deserving now
"Good thinking Markiplier!" THANKS! I think a lot with my brain in my head!
At least I think it's in my head, I've never seen it before!
Ok then "Looks like it's already fully charged, that was fast" well damn
Wapam!
Those things go good, so now that I got that battery I can pop it in the Central System
I guess me just walking around with this light bulb, like if it's supposed to be up in the Tower
I imagine that it somehow amplifies the whole deal, but just me walking around with this light bulb
must be like a source of incredible power in the palm of my hands
which would be astonishing just to carry around this world's sun
and then no one here, that I've met yet, is trying to take it from me, you know what I mean?
because I don't know if it's all robots around here, I don't know if that's the case
it might just be that the robots were made to serve a purpose obviously and then they are
quote unquote "tamed"
you know, and then they have sentience I guess? I mean the Prophet Bot is not tamed and obviously
doesn't have sentience, 'cause it can't make choices for itself, but that other bot can
I don't even remember it's name now, Silver?
"A rectangle-shaped hole..." yep, so we put the charged battery in there
lets hope the charged battery does something...MWOMMM oh shit
"Whoa!"
what did that do? I mean that's a lot for one single battery to b-WOAH
It charged everything!?
"I AM FUNCTIONAL!" "DID YOU POWER THE GENERATOR?"
"I guess we did, right Markiplier?" Hell yeah we did, you know we did
hello..."I AM FUNCTIONALLLL, I CAN WALK" aw good for you, I'm happy to help I guess
I dunno celebrate it for a while 'til the power runs out I guess
oh- "I see you've  made progress in the world, but that progress stops here."
"I believe you need a code to unlock a certain box."
"Well, the code no longer exists in THIS world."
*desktop noise* OHHHHHHHHHHHHHH NO YOU DONT
OH NO NO THAT'S BAD, I do, yeah I do "Good. Start looking."
Where should I look? where would I look-oh, nope not there, ok
Start looking...
Great, so now it's somewhere in my computer, where the heck would that be?
I dunno...I don't know where would it be? Is it behind the screen? no, not behind the screen
Ah, I know how to do it, I'll sort by date modified so the most recent one-
AHHHHH
THERE IT IS
OH BOY
What is that?
woAH
ok alright then
"Dear WOBLOBLONEEHYEHYEEYEEYEEYEEYEEWAYIYIYAIYIYAAIIIIIYIYIAYIYIAAAA"
uh...
"YIYIYAIYIYYIYA- message to you, and I'm, afraid I must make it brief"
"I have left you a journal, part of which is written in a languaged that-OYIYAYIYAYAAAAAAAIYIYYIYAYIYAI"
uhhhhhhh
"EEead it and you will know what to do"
"I have also AYIYAYIYAYIYAYIYAIIII..." uhh
"the code you need is 298578.."
ok so I know that so- I'll just but that over here
I'll just put that over there, TWO NINE EIGHT
five SEVEN EIGHT
I got it! I got all that... I think ok so now that I have that, 298578
*Mark confident on his incorrectly read code*
Got it, I think, this is all going sooo well for me
I don't feel like my privacy has been invaded at allllllllll
alright, that's so cool though
that is...AHH it's cool
so...I'm guessing that only powered the ba- the-the robots in that room
It didn't power everything else so the robot that's in the rowboat, the roboat bot
the rowbot I guess, the ro, r-o-w-bot isn't powered yet because there needs to be something else for that
so then... that told me that the code is to the safe, so I guess that is my only alternative right now
I have to go open that safe to see what's inside
I have this bad habit of- why I didn't find that camera in the last one, I have this bad habit of
being apprehensive to continue on before I found everything, especialy if it's something
that I'm very, very interesting- interested in seeing absolutely everything
ah man, "it's locked with a six digit code" I REMEMBER SEEING A CODE, man, it's weird 'cause for Niko, this has got to be bizarre
Like for Niko, he's just trusting that I know everything, and yet, in his mind I could be setting up everything just to mess with him
"Woah, it worked, wait how did you know the code? I still don't remember seeing one"
"I had some help"... "I have my ways!"~ I'm a mysterious being!~
Ah, if I suggest that I had some help that might tell Niko that there's others like me
I guEsS...
Ima IM AN HONEST GUY, I had some help "Really? from who?" yep, don't worry about it
well now he's just curious, ok maybe, what's in the safe Niko? "alright, let's see"
"Ah! found a gas mask, also there's this weird looking book, I can't read it though"
"not that I can't read or anything! Because I can! I just don't know what language this is..."
Is it French? Tell me it's French, or maybe German...or Korean maybe
alright so what have we got-*glitchy noise* woah...
HIII...HELloooo? "What IS that?" Idun-idunno...
I don't know what that is...
I'd like to know what that is, but I don't know what that is...
imjusgunna
anything else popped up in these documents? Nooo?
Ok, alright then... guess I'm just gonna ignore that...
So if we put on the gas mask, "I'll wear it when I have to" oh ok, what about the strange journal?
"Found in the Barrens, It's written in an unknown language"
alrighty then I guess...
Just-just gonna walk past the weird glitch thing over there... not gonna worry about that at all...
ok, but if I go up here, I know this is where the gas mask is needed.
"I should be fine with this gas mask on" aw you look so scary too
Alright, so why is it all gaseous here?
It's a gas vent but what type of gas?
Why would there just be gas shooting up out of the ground here?
It could be from the phosphorus, that would add a lot of problems.
"Hello person!"
"Welcome to the old chemical processing plant!"
"Most of the equipment has already been relocated"
Alrighty then, thank you Mr. Robot!
What do we have here?
"It's a pair of rubber gloves, they're a bit heavy"
Oh no, weak baby arms.
"Hello person!"
"The robot assembly and repair services have been discontinued at the barrens"
"If you have further inquiry, please contact the head engineer"
Alright then,
Who is that?
This seems to be a page ripped out of a book.
"-cannot overstate the importance of cleaning solvents in this environment"
"Here is a simple recipe using the alternative method discussed in the last chapter, utilizing the natural properties of blue phosphor"
"Reagents: -Acidic gas -Blue phosphor, rare form"
"In a well ventilated area, direct the gas into the container of your choice. Seal immediately"
Well maybe that's all of the steps, but I have funny feeling that there's something missing to that
so something about rare blue phosphor and then gas which I'm sure there is an abundance of around here
Ah, so weird though
Why is there just gas everywhere?
Why? I-I saw that page I'm gonna go back for it just..you know...okay, I'm gonna go back
Just-just I wanna make sure, you know, I just wanna make sure there's nothing else of extreme value before I do that
"There's something weird about the robots who get sent to work near the gas fields"
"They appear to accumulate rust at a much slower rate than others"
"The few who work directly with gas harvesting look practically new!"
"Is that a result of the atmosphere, or am I just seeing things?"
Well, imagine if you're an engineer, you wouldn't just be seeing things. You'd know whether a robot is rusted or not
That must be either a t-uHhhhhh hey, hey big guy
"Oh, hello"
"What are you doing here?"
"Hm?"
"A living person such as yourself should have evacuated this place long ago"
"Oh, but I just got here!  To this world I mean. See? I have the sun!"
"Oh. The Messiah. I... do not know what to say"
Greetings-"Greeting you was not part of my programming"
Even though I just tried to do that
"Have you.. spoken.. to Prophetbot?"
"I think so, yeah!"
"Prophetbot was built with the sole purpose of greeting you"
"Really?"
"Yes. He cannot speak with anyone else. At least, not with ease"
"Oh.."
"That's kind of sad"
"What are you built for then?"
"My purpose is to guard this settlement"
"Even though the residents have long gone, I must remain"
"Ah.."
"Why though?"
"I have not been tamed"
"Tamed?"
"It was not worth the effort"
Oh..
Well that's kinda, that's kinda sad too why-why-why-wa-wa-what is the taming process and what does it mean for these robots here?
Like, what does that include?
"By the way, some robots may start following you around this settlement as well"
Oh, hello
Ok, hi, uh..that's a little weird
"Do not be alarmed. It is their job to keep people safe"
"uNIT RM-2883417 REPORTING FOR DuTY"
"I saw that you spoke with the guardian of the settlement"
"I will now escort you until you reach your dormitory"
"Uhh...what?"
K, thank youuuu, 288. I'm gonna call you that 'cause that's all the numbers that I remember here
Ooo what do we 'ave 'ere?
"Looks... like the're evacuating the few tamed robots we have here" sorry, just had a mental fart in the middle of that.
"Makes sense, no point in keeping them in the Barrens if all the people are already gone"
"I wonder if the engineer is going too"
"Apparently, phase 1 of the evacuation ended prematurely"
"The big ships started malfunctioning only after a few round trips"
"They said it was due to something with squares?
"I'm not sure what they mean by that"
"Bummer, looks like they won't be able to transport most of these surplus bots to the city at this rate
"And we worked so hard on those!"
"But I suppose the rowbots"- OOOOOHHHHH THEY ARE ROWBOTS did I make that up or did I already read that?
I dunno
"-are busy enough with transporting people as is, I think it's going to be our turn soon..."
damn
some sort of crazy evacuation thing
"looking a little dim there...power cell I think...writing on the side, it says Guardian of Residential Area"
So that's powering the big robot, but he seems to be running out of a bit of power oowoah
Hidey hidey hidey ho, that's a lot of holes
ok, can I go up there?
I guess not "I'm scared of ladders"
Ah Niko come on! You're scared of smashy things and you're scared of falling from incredible heights and dying
Geez Louise
"Some of the ink on this page is faded"
"-likely due to some sort of electrical or magnetic interference."
"I'm afraid this operation can no longer be sustained, if the servers continue to fail so much that maintenance cannot keep up the pace."
"Fortunately, it does not seem to be happening to the robots. At least, not at a significant rate. Time will tell."
So that's why all the computer systems are broken, they're just falling apart.
"Checking... CHECKING..."
"Terminal does not respond."
"This is a PROBLEM."
Indeedy-doo it is, keep checking I suppose.
"All of these terminals do not boot."
"Also they are cracked and are full of holes."
"I am not sure what to do now."
I suppose keep checking?
eh
It's weird because,
They're - they're not tamed, so to speak, but they seem to have some sort of understanding of the world.
And are not sure what to do,
so their programming might just be more suggestions just like the prophetbot cant speak to anybody else,
with ease.
"Y'know, I've never been around so many robots before, Markiplier!"
"Or... Any robots at all..."
"I mean, I see them in cartoons and stuff, but I've never seen one in person!"
"They're pretty neat, don't you think?"
hey niko do a robot voice
Well that's just mean!
"DANCE FOR ME MONKEY DAAANCE"
Yeah.
Yeah!
well then maybe i should've seen the robot voice...
Oh hello!
Hi there!
"HELLO!"
"Hi!"
"What are you doing up there?"
"I am stAtioned here."
"By yourself?"
"YES!"
ok...
aw...
Maybe I could talk to him?
"HELLO!"
Ok.
"Still stationed here!"
"Thanks for visiting me again!"
"No one's ever visited me TWICE."
"You are so nice."
alrighty then
Man...
Is this a nonstop row of just...
Various robot dormitories?
"Hey sweetie, six more weeks until you can come home!"
" 'Bout time, huh?"
"Gosh, I can't imagine living in that awful capsule wall...dorm...thing!"
"But guess what? Soon you'll get to sleep in a real bed again and eat real food again."
"Write back soon!"
"Love, Mom."
"Aw..."
Oh no.
These aren't robot dorms...
These are holes in the wall that people slept in.
"Looks like we're supposed to pack stuff for the evacuation starting today,"
"I wish these books weren't so heavy,"
"It's gonna be a pain to carry them onto the ship."
"But they're by the author! I can't just throw them away.."
The author? Question mark?
Who is 'the author'?
I have no idea..
God, I can't imagine living in just..
A big ass sloo..
Of holes in the wall.
I guess, you know, in the end, you only need to really sleep
So long as it's moderately comfortable,
I guess it wouldn't be the *worse* thing in the world but
S- Even so.. that's like..
That's kinda horrible.
Oh this is the other gas mask area.
Was there anything other there that I needed? I don't think so.
So, eventually I need to cycle back..
and..
and what? Oh did I get any other items? I guess I got rubber gloves..
But I guess that's only to be able to do um
The instructions that it was giving me, oh! Hello.
"This vent is on the ground!"
"All the others are taller than me."
So I could probably use this vent!
"Initially, the amount of noxious fumes emitted by the natural gas vents caught our team off-guard.
Thank goodness the medical team reacted as quickly as they did."
"Despite it's failure, that first expedition did bring up some interesting observations about the Barrens
We found that there's not one, but two such vent zones."
"With fumes being pumped out at such high concentrations, it seems a miracle the gas hasn't spread anywhere else."
"Our biologists concluded that the phosphor shrimp in the crater pools were actively consuming the gas.."
The shrimp in the ocean also prevent the gas from wafting off into the Glen."
"If that's the case, then we owe a lot to these little guys!"
Best not to scoop 'em up and then shtuff 'em into jars!!
Maybe I could capture some of this..
In the bottle..
"I guess you want me to fill the bottle with gas?"
Yes?
"That oughta do it.."
Okay! So I got a bottle of smoooke?
So I have that? I guess? That's good,
So what do I do with that though..
'Cause there's tons of gas vents around here..
But that's the only one that's accessible to me..
And I'm imagining that has to do with the combination they were talking about..
So that I can make some sort of thIING that I don't understand what is, hello bubble!!
"This pond sure looks different, this water looks like jelly? Formed a bubble over the surface.."
Well what do I do with that?? Do I introduce the smoke to it?
"Fill the bottle with this stuff?" Alright okay..
Okay cool..
But that means the smoke escaped so maybe it's like the second step..
Yup.
"It's too goopy to fit in the bottle opening"?
"It's like one time years ago when I tried to put tomato chowder in a baby bottle.."
..Why did you try to put tomato chowder in a baby bottle?
Eugh
"The grownups thought it was hilarious" Oh..!
Do you have a baby.. like, brother or sister?
They taught you how to use funnels?? "And then they also told me I should not try to babysit until i'm older.."
"Anyway we should probably look for a funnel or something.."
OKay!!
Alright I need a funnel to do that.. Oh hello!
What are you doin' off by yourself?
"The sky is dark.."
"That it is,"
"Do you know when the sun will be back up???"
"We're working on it!!"
I've got the sun in my hands right now! Please don't,
freak out or anything, but i'm kinda a big deal.
I'm ah, i'm the messiah and I talk to a god on a regular basis~
I know, I know, i'm probably blowin' your mind right now.
But don't worry bout it. Perfectly normal for someone who lives such a interesting and amazing life such as me.
But ah, I guess you wouldn't understand anything like that being a *robot*.
Okay, so I just cycled back to where I was,
So if I have to imagine I have to do anything else it has to be in that other gas vent
Or, to the east of that other gas zone,
Cause I don't know if I went fully that direction yet.
So i'll be right back!!
"UNIT RT-384721 REPORTIN' FOR DUTAYY!"
"It seems you already have an assigned escort, unit RM-2883417"
"Wouldja like me to leave?"
"You can follow me if you want."
"UUUNDERSTOOOD"
"I will now escort you until you reach your dormitory."
Okay thank you!
I don't know which one's mine. I don't think any of these are mine-
'Infirmary', okay, alright then
"HELLO ORGANIC PERSON WHO IS ALIVEE!!"
"THE INFIRMARY IS UPAHEADD."
Incase you need it for your organic fleshy organs!!
The things with which you need..
"HELLO PERSON OF ORGANIC MMAKEUP!"
"WWELCOME TO THE INFIRMARY."
"Scanning for injuries.."
"Um..."
"Scan complete!!"
"Injuries detected: ..None."
"Treatment required: ..None."
"You are good to go."
Thank you!
Okaay, if I ever get injured I come down here.
'S a box of medical tools.. Most are broken or rusted..
Plastic syringe seems to be okay..!
Maybe I could use that..
To put the stuff in the bottle..
"Hello person are you seeking admission to the infirmary???"
"Oh. Carry on then."
Thank you.. Bye you were so helpful.
So maybe..
If this needle is particularly long,I should be able to technically..
Can't combine those, but,
I don't want to go back just yet until i've found absolutely everything, but,
it might be something worth trying out.
because- i- well then again I don't know if..
Hm..
I dunno..
It- It maybe.. I don't know how small these shrimp are, if their gonna be actually sucked up into a syringe..
Wait, okay,
"These boards seem to be loose, though, I should be able to pull them off with the right tool.."
I haaave a crowbar!!
"Good thing I kept this crowbaAR"
Yeah good thing Niko, I suggested it to you. As your overlord.
"What a workout.."
I know Niko.. Physically labor- ooo.
That's a little disturbing..
"Buncha' robots without power. I guess a generator can only do so much.."
Man that's amazing, just, a slight dab of the sun on a battery, and all these things get powered.."
"It's a big metal box with complicated machinery.."
"Robot looks rustyyy.. Complicated machinery..." Alright,
"Without breaking the seal, inject the liquid phosphor into the container."
"Shake vigorously to initiate the reaction."
"Use as soon as possible..."
Inject.. So I do need to put the smoke in first, keep it sealed, then use the syringe to get it in there and then shake..
"Hand protection is critical after this step, the resulting acid is moderately stronger than common household cleaners.."
"I don't know what half these words mean, it's good thing you're here, Markiplier!" YEAH, I KNOW~
I KNOW WHAT THOSE MEAN..
A cleaning sponge with a rough surface..
Okay, alright, I got that?
I don't think there's anything else in here, so I can move on.
Maybe I could use the cleaning sponge on the big robot, give him a good ol'..
Scruubuh
He seems to be a little.. worse for wear these days so it's possible..
that, he'd appreciate it!
Maybe it's just a nice thing to do! Maybe it's not essential to the story, but maybe y'know,
Maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea.
Here ah,
lemme give ya a good, a good lil',
you wanna scrub??
"Stay safe."
Alrighty then.
You're so nice.
You're so nice to me..
Oh, something over here..?
Mmm..
nOpe that's not it.
Alright i'll be right back I know what I need to do now.
Bottle on that? Yup.
FILL IT UP.
Boopity boop.
And seal it off! Okay, so you gotta bottle of smoke,
With, hopefully, a good seal on it,
And don't pull that cork off!! Whatever you do!!
We're gonna suck up some phosphor!
Shrimp.
Then we're gonna do our deed here..
Let's- "So we're filling the syringe?"
"I guess it's kinda like a funnel."
"But the liquid might be too thick to fit in the needle.."
TRY.
"Hey, it actually went in!"YES.
You need to believe and trust me.
"Gross"
I agree
But anyway,
Let's see, uhhh
Now we just combine this, with a bottle of smoke
"I should inject the liquid through the cork right?"
"ITS LIKE IMA DOCTOR!"
Of bottles..
So now you have..
"Oh I should probably shake this too.."
That's what the instructions said. "It changed color!"
I have bottle of acid now.
GOOD! WHAT DO I DO WITH THAT..
Why do I need a bOTTLe of acid??
I'm supposed to use it, like, right away..
But i don't know where to go for that..
Theres gotta be something that's rusted over, that needs to be utilized, maybe the robot.
Could the robot maybe need this? AY BUDDY?
AY BUDDY BOO, you wanna- you wanna be doused in acid??
Ooh-!
"I AM FUNCTIONALLLL!
"WAS IT YOU WHO FIXED THE GENERATOR????"
"well markiplier helped me, but yeah."
"Hello! nice to meet you. I am Rowbot #310."
"WOUld you like me to take you somewhere???"
"are you okay?" "I cannot move." "Well, you're still really rusty."
"That is true.
"Hold on... Markiplier and I will find a way to help you."
Waddabout this SPONGE??
"I'm guessing you want me to pour this acid on the sponge?" YES.
MY RAMPANT ATTEMPT TO COMBINE ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING IS EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
"Good thing I had these gloves
"I hope this works.
I got a wet sponge and no more acid- keewl"
"Alright hold still" "I have no other choice"
There. How's that?"
"I... can move again..! Thank you!!"
"I am able to fulfill my purpose again! Where would you like to go??"
"Can you take me to the tower?"
"Calculating.. Closest destination to the tower.. Is the glen, port number..."
"My built in navigation circuits have fried.
"I'm gonna assume that;s not good." "that is not good at all."
"Once again I cannot follow my programming."
"is there anything I can do to help?
"In the event of a error, you should speak with the head engineer.  She should know what to do."
The head engineer? *She* will know what to do.. Talking' bout silver??
YOU TALKIN' BOUT SILVER BUDDY BOO??
You talking about silver? You talking about silver?? They might be talking' bout silver there.
But unfortunately I do not have anymore time in this episode to pursue that, so i'm gonna put Niko to bed,
Before I actually close out the game here- "I'm not sleepy anymore"..
WELL I DONT KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN YOU HAVETA TALK ABOUT THAT CAUSE I NEED TO GO.. I GUESS.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching, hopefully, Niko doesn't mind being shunted in the darkness..
As I close the game, but,
Hopefully you guys are enjoying this, I will get to more episodes of this soon,
So thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you think down in the comments below,
And as always, I will see you, IN the next video, BYE BYE!
Subtitle author(s) note: This episode took forever to subtitle, hope you enjoyed!